gehen wir einfach mal den deckeln hier
an und wie will
[Musik]
aber wisst ihr dass gegen wie dieses t
shirt hier für mich angekommen ist und
ich weiß nicht ob ich das ding behalten
soll weil ich meine größe xl ist
übrigens gerade vergessen habe mein
politik entwickelt gerade auf wasser und
einer scheibe brot das ist luxus ist
super ich wollte nur sagen dass ich eine
viertelstunde später kommen dann kannst
du das recht er hat eben ausrichten bei
hasenberger wieder viel zu lange die
hier unter mache die migration von hier
unten oder nicht die buchmacher auswege
vorbild meine haare nicht mehr los
halbjahr habe ich meine haare oben so
ein bisschen gibt er hat manchmal nur
stehen gehabt ihre zeit komplett gewährt
aber jetzt wenn sie komplett wieder nett
direktorin beate friese hier mit
irgendwas fehlt aber egal das video
sieht dekan auch nicht treffe ich jetzt
mit marken für markt noch eben ein paar
koffer holen müssen und alltag kommt ist
noch nicht mehr gestern wieder gekauft
das ist einfach so fucking geil
hab übrigens im block vorgestern gesagt
dass ich euch beide überzeugten afrika
habe das werde ich gleich tun auf jeden
fall wechseln
sommer ein sommer wieder durch michael
haftung da hinten gelaufen
[Musik]
das kannst du so dumm für 14 euro kaufen
das soll das alles gold vorne zu bringen
gerade partien für meinen blog gedreht
ihr werdet schon freunde die mir schon
am start schrecklichen trägt man dabei
hatten katastrophen kraftwerk
[Musik]
[Applaus]
du kannst bewegen was der liebe freiheit
disco unternimmt kontinenten nein wir
fahren übrigens die kinder an bei dem
wir auch schon im letzten block waren
aber was wir heute noch
das war das wo wir mit diana waren dann
wird doch verloren
vielleicht haben wir heute auf weiter
versucht freunde vielleicht haben wir
heute offen
guckt man heute dieser konflikt genauso
aus wie der sprechende koffer von kika
früher kauften lena sättel und haben
acht play unter 300 bin ich mir dabei an
den typen wie träsch 2000 euro also wir
fahren jetzt wieder vom nächsten
möbelladen gefahren und sie haben ein
ultra geil geil
wir sind jetzt wieder bei mir angekommen
[Musik]
insgesamt leben das video aufgenommen
haben essen wir dachten was und danach
werde ich euch was es mit dem titel auf
sich hat
video aufgenommen freunde sichtbar
gemacht wird der backofen es noch haben
darf und fertig vor zwei tagen im blog
ich schon gesagt habe dass ich mit
erfolg zeigen werde ob sie die
titelgewinne eingeblendet und die welt
befinde krippenfeier gesehen hätte
eingewendet ein neues haustier rund 280
vorsieht sei in seiner verpackung und
man muss sie ab weiß ganz genau wie das
funktioniert versteckte tieren blitz an
den eiern daten die herschel darauf
entdeckt zu werden hier ihnen beim
schlüpfen und lass mich verzaubert von
ihrer funkelnden marienkäfer mal den
deckel der an und wird ich weiß nicht
worauf greifen
reisen später die sollten kind auch
bekommen
ich musste noch weitere schraube
ebenfalls gehen oder ding hier etwas
dünnere packung pdfs was hier tritt man
ich hab die bis heute abgesehen
übrigens anders ging später mal irgendwo
aussehen oder so also wir brauchen den
namen freundeskreis meinen namen und in
die kommentare nicht erkennen soll jetzt
endlich mal geschluckt wird man jetzt
steht man wolle den schiffen dass man
mit dem schier über man gegend gelockt
also doch das eiland sich auch gegenüber
meinen wir das auch kann die meiste zeit
freundin vorgehen jede farbe gebietet
uns gerade da serviert beispielsweise
dieses blau oder grün wo das ding
irgendwie wir gerochen hat m steht für
eine bestimmte sache dass ein gerade
haben möchte denn das einzelne gerade so
hell beleuchtet geht jedoch weiter
gegeben werden dass wir fällt ihm jetzt
in rot und dabei ronstedt hierunter
weite teile bleiben halt die fresse ich
wieder dass wir diese sei einfach mal
mitnehmen weil ich will nicht alles
kriegt ihr auch gerade mit den augen ich
will ja nicht alles von dem ein die im
heutigen blog machen sondern solle
sondern in bing werden dafür dazu über
blogs dass derzeit ein ausschluss
deswegen will ich sagen ich denke ich
jetzt ein bisschen ein hier du kennt
wird auf jeden fall eine kleine rolle
und ich würde sagen wir sehen uns dann
im nächsten block wieder gottes macht
das worum genau es gar keine augen mehr
ich glaube schläft ich bin eigentlich
ganz nah zu machen während das ein
nebenan schläft in jedem block bedingt
an jedem tag
mal schauen wie sie irgendwann wissen
dann schlüpft führen dann habe ich
endlich mal einen freund heute wie
magath verrät ich gedacht gar nicht
reportieren also ich war schon relativ
viel verdient und den habe ich noch
einmal etliche bachelorarbeit
präsentation also ich bedanke sind jetzt
so in 2000 jahren wieder 2000 jahre
später 1000 jahre später gerade halb
nach und halten
[Musik]
guten morgen mein das hat sich irgendwie
falsch ein wunderschöner morgen ist
angebrochen
dass alle redet schon wieder alles klar
bei dir ich glaube zurück während ich
das eingefahrene noch ein bisschen
liegen lassen weil er halt immer so ein
bisschen vom langschläfer typ wie
eigentlich immer man braucht was ich
aber auf jeden fall heute etwas machen
wollten händen da drin immer noch hinzu
schreibt ich weiß halt nicht wieder klar
dieses allerdings trifft das heißt ich
würde sagen wir völlig reichen da wird
man wieder von bmw 3er will unterdessen
streit gekommen
das ist viel weniger von wetter und
immer eher dunkel ist und ihr kommt die
farbe besser denen ich kann die fahrt
noch verfehlen dabei liebe ich erst mal
einen tag heute lebt mein tag vor grad
alter bub chris leben nicht glaube ich
probiert man sowieso zu retten nicht
immer etwas übrig auch eine neue
kategorie die glocken und war luca
argumentiert kommentar
es geht darum dass ich mir ein
tachometer unserem letzten block
anschauen
die kommentieren lukas block 52 prozent
auf dem klo künftig wurden laut schleife
ist der erste youtube jetzt beim duschen
fällt leider auch die wahrheit die
fliege weiß und rot weißen block von
verlagen sich gewinn habe gerettet weil
ich bei mir im nacken rücken von
pendlern ein wie war nicht so tot wie
wirklich geflogen ich habe ich ihnen
erzähle ich habe mich getraut die krise
sprechen machen ich habe sie auch mit
ihr gehirn werden auch an mich
anzusprechen eine neue einladung nicht
blog machen ich liebe deine videos aber
auch noch von langweiligen reifen
begraben liegt meine videos aber lockt
und langweilig meint meine blogs
sandloch auch meine regierung ist darauf
angelegt weil es für mich einfach
billiger ist ich bin einfach fragen hat
irgendwie in tante anna die gruppe macht
alle zwei tage war dem video ist für
mich einfach erfährt am entspanntesten
und das heißt nicht dass ich anderen
parteien bringen zum beispiel die
tageweise reagiert machen das kommt
einfach einen block mit reinweißen aber
das waschen von der heutigen episode von
lukas kommentiert
die mich im letzten block vermittelte
bei den deutschen firma beschwert habe
meinten einige haye im park verfolgte
besser werden da steht nur reden für
köln holte dort freunde dass der regen
regen regen
ich habe mir gerade macht bei apple
gestellt und als medienangaben mit der
festen übergeben hat meinte di bis do
umgezogen nicht einer von halben jahr
leitet die ag hsh nordbank macht monaten
da was über knochen seiner alten wohnung
und in dem moment wo bach hat die verein
kranke gedächtnis kann mir nicht mal
merken was ich heute morgen gefrühstückt
haben und erstmals auch richtig und
erstmals eine schöne stadt die wahrheit
ist einfach ich bin immer als erste
haben fünf immer muss ich auf mack
warten sagt die hübsche wichtig ab jedes
mal warte ich auf den er kommt immer zu
spät
[Musik]
die frage ist ob ich möchte euch nun zum
abendessen machen oder ob ich mir frei
machen
das hier habe ich einfach alles gerade
noch gewaschen und nein das ist nicht
das verbietet allerdings schon relativ
spät ich hätte ihnen noch duschen und
schlafen wir wirklich den blogger oliver
steller jetzt beenden wenn euch
geteilter das gerne mal leicht da würde
ich mich darüber freuen wenn noch kein
abonnent könnt ihr gerne einen kanal
abonnieren findet ihr einfach unter dem
video abonnieren knopp und wenn ich von
abonnenten könnt ihr auch diese glocke
hier klicken
denn dann bekommt die benachrichtigungen
natürlich sagen wir und übermorgen einen
neuen traum wieder wenn ihr daran die
huber kommentiert kommentare fraktion
reinhold schneider auf ihren kommentaren
zu diesem video und soll
[Musik]